I'm thrilled and delighted
to welcome you to the Library
of Congress National
Book Festival
and to our fourth
annual Youth Poetry Slam.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
This year we have
slammers from two teams
who traveled quite long
distances to compete.
So I'm going to announce them.
Please join me in
welcoming, first,
from somewhat nearby
Boston, Mass LEAP.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
And from the other
coast in Sacramento,
the Sacramento Area
Youth Speaks.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
These two teams made
the final stage
of the 2018 Brave New Voices
International Youth Poetry
Festival this last July.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
And we are very happy to feature
representatives from both.
We are also thankful
to Youth Speaks
and to their new
executive director,
Christy Limon Johnston [sic],
they are the organization behind
the festival, for their help
in bringing final stages
teams and poets to the slam.
I'm sorry to say that the
slammers from Dew More Poetry,
the 2018 Brave New Voices Slam
champions from nearby Baltimore,
were scheduled to be
here tonight, but,
unfortunately, had to cancel.
But we do want to honor them
and their championship team,
so we have a video from
this year's performance
that we'd like to show.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> [exhales loudly] Fatherhood
left my mother pregnant
with absence.
>> Breastfed me broken promises.
>> [in unison] My
father knows the neck
of liquor bottles better
than he knows my name.
My Father loves his spirits just
like he loves being
one in my life.
But now poetry has
been the best father
since the biological one left.
>> Having an addict for a father
and a soldier for a mother,
the war on drugs will
happen on my homeland.
While she shot up people,
he shot up himself,
and I'm the one left for dead.
>> Having a coffin for a mother
and a criminal for
a sperm donor --
>> [in unison] You learn
to live outside the box.
>> You become so
numb, like a robot.
But how do you explain
to the world
that you have a barely
functioning motherboard?
>> [in unison] And
then poetry came
and raised me from
my broken home.
Words became magical.
Maybe that's why they
call it spelling.
Through this American horror
story we coveted our pain.
But poetry taught us to
drop houses on our sorrows.
>> Meaning we used to
live in our depression --
>> [in unison] Now we fight it.
Boxed out my black out
for the title champion.
>> All the times he told me I
wasn't man enough blaming the
women in my life
for my female traits
>> [in unison] He liked
to talk with his fists,
but got mad when I
talk with my hands.
>> Only appears to appease.
Becomes a vanishing act
when it's time to raise.
>> Never taught me how to fight,
so I got jumped more
times the amount
of times I prayed
for you to save me.
Changed my praying
hands into fists.
>> [in unison] Became
my own guardian angel
when you had no more to give.
Dad, you are no savior.
You just think you're God.
That's why we can't
see or hear you.
And our family forces
us to praise you.
>> I remember when
my mother died.
I couldn't tell which
was more cold --
my mother's or my father's
shoulder, or my mother's body.
I just didn't want to lose
all this joy in the morning.
But --
>> [in unison] And
there's always a but.
Poetry taught me commas in place
of periods, taught me resilient
in place of malecide,
taught me metaphors
in place of self-mutilation.
And isn't that what it
means to be a father?
When I'm slammed, I'm not
doing it for the points,
I'm doing it for all the love.
>> I remember when I
wrote my depression poem.
Four people told me I gave them
the strength to finish theirs.
>> I remember [inaudible]
me and [inaudible]
to perform our abortion poem.
Our tears and smiles
was all I needed,
after having a life sucked out
of me, only took three minutes
to breathe it back in.
>> [in unison] Meaning
we were fatherless,
but now our poetry
family raises us.
If it takes a village,
then I got that.
Fatherhood left my mother
pregnant with absence.
Breastfed me broken promises.
But what's a deadbeat
dad to a self-love poem?
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Although we wish Baltimore
was here with us, we are happy
to have our local slam team
and our hometown pride.
So as with every National Book
Festival Youth Poetry Slam,
we are excited to introduce
the D.C. Youth Poetry Slam team
members and the team.
Please give it up for them.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Before I turn things over
to our emcee, Joseph Green,
who's done this poetry slam
for the last three years,
I'd like to say a few words
about our slam partner,
Split This Rock.
It's hard to imagine
where poetry
across the country would be
today without the organization.
And, of course, the
organization would not exist
without all the hard
work of co-founder
and executive director,
Sarah Browning.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
After ten incredible years,
Sarah has decided it's time
to turn the reins
over to another leader
as she goes off and
studies poetry.
Sarah, you have been a
force of good in my life,
and in the lives
of so many others.
And you've wowed the
Librarian of Congress, too.
She's hoping to make
it here tonight
to catch a little bit
of the poetry slam.
One of her first official acts
as the Librarian of Congress was
to come here and
be a judge in 2016.
But she did give me a little
something to pass along to you.
So if you could come
up onto the stage?
[ Cheering and Applause ]
So Sara this is a
rare harD.C.over copy
of "American Journal:
Fifty Poems for Our Time."
This is Tracy K.
Smith's anthology
that is just coming out, part
of her second term project,
signed by the Librarian herself
with great love and affection.
So thank you, Sarah.
[ Applause ]
It was really my pleasure.
And now Joseph Green.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Welcome.
[ Laughter ]
You expected it to be
more exciting, I know.
[ Laughter ]
Welcome to the Library of
Congress Youth Poetry Slam.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
I invite you to make
some more noise.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Do you feel like you've
made enough noise?
[ Laughter ]
I don't feel like you
made enough noise.
Let me put that in perspective.
Today, as you just witnessed,
you are about to listen to some
of the most powerful
voices of a generation.
Young people who have been given
a space and a stage and a pen
to write down the story
that they already had,
but we too often do not listen
to, they're going to come
up here, and something
miraculous is going to happen.
You're going to feel connection
without anybody touching you.
There's going to be something
profound going on in this room.
I was raised in the south during
the summer times, and I would go
to church with my grandma.
And they would sing,
better than I can sing,
because I can't sing, "Are
You Ready for a Miracle?"
And the church would sing
back, "Ready as I can be."
Are you ready for a miracle?
>> [multiple speakers]
Ready as I can be.
>> Library of Congress Youth
Poetry Slam make some noise!
[ Cheering ]
That feels better, that feels
better, that feels better.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Welcome. My name is Joseph Green
and I will be your
host this evening.
I have a co-host, who
will be sitting over here.
She is the director of youth
programs at Split This Rock.
Her name is Chelsea.
Everyone give Chelsea
a round of applause.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
We'll be talking back and
forth as the slam goes.
Chelsea, say "what's
up" to everybody.
>> What's up everybody?
[ Laughter ]
>> Just like that.
You can feel the
connection, right?
We've been practicing the
five minutes before the show.
We just decided to do this.
It's going to be crazy.
Things that you guys need
to know about, this program,
as you heard, was brought to
you not only by the Library
of Congress, but
by Split This Rock.
And a couple of things
that you need to know
about Split This Rock, their
mission is to cultivate,
teach and celebrate
poetry that bears witness
to injustice and
provokes change.
Now, I'm gonna say that
again, because it sounds
like I just read off
a bunch of words.
But I want you to really
listen to what they do,
and what is behind what
we're doing here today.
Split This Rock's
mission is to cultivate,
teach and celebrate
poetry that bears witness
to injustice and
provokes change.
I think that you all can agree
there are some injustices,
and we need to provoke
some change.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
They do a lot of things
at Split This Rock along
with their youth programs.
And as the evening goes by,
I will tell you more
about what they do.
Now I'm going to tell
you why we're here.
Show of hands if you've ever
been to a poetry slam before.
Oh, okay, good.
Show hands of hands if you've
never been to a poetry slam.
Oh, that's gorgeous.
All right, awesome.
People who have been to
poetry slam, say "what's up"
to the people ain't never
been to a poetry slam.
What's up?
What's good?
How you doing?
Nice to have you here.
This is what's gonna
happen today.
We have six amazing performers
who are going to get up here
and share an original
piece of writing
that they wrote themselves.
All right?
There will be no
musical accompaniment,
there will be no props.
And, because this is at the
National Book Festival sponsored
by -- brought to you by
the Library of Congress,
the first poem that each one of
the young people reads has to be
about books or reading
or learning.
Something in that space.
And then the second poem can be
about whatever they
want it to be about.
So you're gonna hear two rounds.
That's 12 poems.
Prepare yourselves.
It's going to be amazing.
Okay? Now, at a poetry slam
it is a competition, right?
So -- I know, right?
Competition, boo, competition.
But it's fun.
It's America.
This is what we do.
All right?
We take an art form
and we deep-fry it,
and we bring it to the world.
[ Laughter ]
And so -- it sounds like
I'm just throwing shade,
but I like fried chicken, so.
The fun part about what we do
is we have some judges here
that will be scoring these
poems from zero to ten.
Zero being the most
magnificent -- excuse me.
[ Laughter ]
Ah, hm. Zero being
-- it's been a while
since I've hosted a slam.
Zero being a -- we'll
call it a bad poem, right?
I don't know -- I don't
know if you want --
how you call a poem
bad, but we'll just say
that that poem probably
shouldn't have made it
to stage today.
I'm pretty much guaranteeing you
195% ain't no zero poems gonna
make it to the stage today.
Now, then there's a ten.
Ten is simultaneous
profound lifting of spirit
of every member of this audience
to another realm of space
and time, understanding,
same time.
Who knows the commercials where
they're little heads pop and,
like, the little
blue smoke comes up?
That happens when the ten goes.
You'll feel it.
It's a metaphor,
but you'll feel it.
All right?
Now, would you like to meet
these magnificent judges
who have volunteered
their time here today?
[ Cheering and Applause ]
All right.
Now, when I say their name
in the midst of their bio,
you're gonna want to make noise.
Let me finish the
bio for the people --
like, the eight people
in the audience
who don't know who they are.
All right?
National Poetry Slam
winner, Elizabeth Acevedo,
lives in Washington, D.C. --
[ Cheering ]
What'd I say?
[ Laughter ]
Lives in Washington, D.C.
Her poetry collections are
"Beastgirl and Other
Myths" [sic]
and "Medusa Reads
La Negra's Palm."
Her new book, "The Poet X,"
from Harper Teen is a New
York Times Bestseller,
a novel written in verse.
Acevedo has a BA from George
Washington University,
and an MFA from the
University of Maryland.
She is a Cave Canem
Fellow, and has participated
in the Callaloo Creative
Writing Workshop.
Please make some noise
for Elizabeth Acevedo!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Natalie E. Illum is a
poet, disability activist
and singer living in Washington,
D.C. She's a 2017 Jenny
McKean Moore Poetry Fellow,
and a recipient of
the 2017 Artist Grant
for the D.C. Arts Commission,
as well as a nonfiction editor
of The Deaf Poets
Society Literary Journal.
She was a founding board
member of Mothertongue,
a women's open mic
that lasted 15 years.
Have you ever been
to an open mic?
One that lasts for 15
years is a great open mic.
She used to compete on the
National Poetry Slam circuit,
and was the 2013 Beltway
Grand Slam Champion.
She has been published
many times.
And she's been on
NPR Snap Judgment.
Please make some noise
for Natalie E. Illum!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
And your last judge,
Javier Zamora,
was born in La Herradura?
>> Yeah.
>> Herroderro?
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
We'll work on it afterwards.
Know that I said it wrong,
and I didn't mean to.
El Salvador in 1990.
At the age of nine he
migrated to the United States
to be reunited with his parents.
Zamora holds a BA
from the University
of California-Berkeley --
>> Yes!
>> Yes, California-Berkeley --
where he studied and taught
in June Jordan's
Poetry for the People.
Yeah, well, if you don't
know, you should know.
Look it up.
And an MFA from New
York University.
He is the author
of "Unaccompanied."
Please give all of your love
and energy to our three judges,
including Javier Zamora!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
All right.
We know what a slam is, we
know who our judges are.
There are a couple of things
that I need to tell you
about how to participate
in this moment.
Okay? So this slam is
not a presentation,
it is a conversation.
>> Right.
>> So when these poets perform,
you need to give them
your energy back, right,
in the form of a response.
That response comes
in a few ways.
One of the ways is snap.
Can I get everyone in
the audience to snap?
>> Hoo!
[ Multiple People
Snapping Fingers ]
Beautiful.
The largest bowl of Rice
Krispies in the world.
I'm so hungry.
Okay. The second thing you
can do, you can say "word."
>> [multiple speakers] Word!
>> On the count of three,
I'm gonna need you to say
"word" with your chest.
One, two, three.
>> [multiple speakers] Word!
>> I appreciate you.
You can make that sound you make
when you have a delicious
piece of chocolate.
Mmm. Don't eat chocolate?
I don't know who you are,
but if you don't eat
chocolate, think mango.
Mmm. I feel like
it got less people.
That's weird.
I love mango and chocolate,
but I'm just crazy.
All right.
Last, but not least, you can
do, what is my favorite way
of showing appreciation,
you can take the word "she,"
you can take the word "Jesus,"
and if you hear something
that makes you feel
particularly holy,
no matter your religious
denomination,
you smoosh those words together,
and it becomes "Shesus."
[ Laughter ]
Now, what I'm about to do will
be a litmus for how much fun
and passion and enjoyment
we're gonna get
out of this event this evening.
I'm going to ask you,
on the count of three,
everyone in this room, to
put your right hand up,
and give me your best Shesus.
All right?
From zero to 100%, we're
gonna tell how it's gonna go
down here.
All right?
On the count of three.
It's better when
you participate!
I'm bracing myself.
One, two, three.
>> [multiple speakers] Shesus!
>> Ohh!
[ Laughter ]
I don't know when you're gonna
have the opportunity to be
in front of a thousand
people you don't know,
and have them say the word
"shesus," right hand up to you.
But if you ever get
that opportunity,
you should pursue
it relentlessly.
[ Laughter ]
Are you ready for a poetry slam?
Say "word."
>> [multiple speakers] Word!
>> You are not ready
for a poetry slam!
>> Why not?
>> And I'll tell you why not,
because before we have a poetry
slam, we must have a poet come
to the stage and calibrate our
judges, because they're rusty.
It's been a year since
we've been here, right?
We gotta make sure that
they're ready for this,
because this is real serious.
So we bring what we
call a sacrificial poet
up to the stage --
[ Cheering ]
And she performs.
Oh, I gave it away.
They perform.
[ Laughter ]
And then we get the scores,
and then we start the slam.
I need y'all like
you are clapping
for your firstborn child
that just won a spelling bee
in a language you did not
know they could speak.
I need you to start clapping
right now for Carlynn Newhouse!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Speak, Carlynn!
>> Whoo!
>> Adjust that mic!
Take your stage!
>> Come on, Carlynn!
>> Black girl ready!
>> They not ready.
>> Yeah!
[ Exhales Loudly ]
>> Dear Marvel, after your
installment of "Black Panther,"
may I suggest a follow-up
movie, a sequel, if you will.
The movie will be about a
superhero, magic, black chick.
We can call her Super
Blackgirl or Afrowoman.
Yeah. Afrowoman.
Drape her cape in royal
purple because she is a queen.
Crown of kinky curls
bestowed upon her.
Let her rock afro
puffs or box braids.
And let the movie's theme
music be gospel hymn meets
Kendrick Lamar.
She can be played by
Viola Davis or Taraji P.,
or any other black woman,
because aren't we all
magic in our own way?
Aren't we superheroes?
Watch as we give birth to a
world full of brown folks.
Watch as white folk tremble
at this gentle giant
we call a black woman.
Ain't a black woman
also food and tsunami
and sweet innocence [inaudible].
Watch as we make the
moon magic out of dust.
Watch as we turn our
tears into a ocean,
into a well for him
to drink from.
Watch as we give all parts of
ourselves and do not disappear.
But we do know black
women disappear.
Easy. Left no trace like
evaporated instant smoke.
Ain't that proof that
a black woman is magic,
that we feed the world, and
we're then abracadabra'd away?
Can't we at least
have a Marvel movie,
or a day we don't fear our
children dying in front of us?
So give us a movie, Marvel, and
let it be called "Afrowoman."
The movie supervillain
can be the personification
of white supremacy, or
Becky with the good hair,
or an evil clone played
by Rachel Dolezal.
Afrowoman's powers include
reversing the bullets,
giving birth to a
revolution of invisibility.
Also, hypervisibility.
The metaphor being that black
women are always ignored
or exploited.
Her invisibility powers are
on a set of bangle bracelets.
The metaphor being that
black women can be heard,
but not seen, like screams
or ghosts or gunshots.
And when Afrowoman
defeats the villain,
because she will
defeat the villain,
for once, she will be the hero.
For once, she will
not take second place
to something whites
or masculine.
For once, the black woman wins.
And at the end of the movie I
want a scene where she marches
down the street, all bantu
knots and combat boots,
and a million black
women march behind her.
The metaphor being that behind
every great black woman is a
thousand other great
black women.
The street ahead is
dark and unknown.
Afrowoman shines all
the light in the galaxy.
And this will not be a metaphor
or an explanation for anything.
After all, we all know
black women are magic.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Okay. Okay.
Okay.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Y'all ready?
>> [multiple speakers] Yeah.
>> I want to make sure
that you're ready,
because you might hear
some things this evening
that might contrast
your world view.
You might hear some
things this evening
that make you question
or wonder.
You might hear some
things this evening
that make you want
to learn more.
You might hear some things
this evening you completely
disagree with.
But that's why we're here.
We're here to grow and build
community, to celebrate voices
that are not celebrated on a
regular basis, and to make space
for all the voices, because
this stage and this world
and this literature,
this spoken word,
these poems that we do
have room for all of us,
a vision of all of us.
So I hope that you're
ready, because I get tired,
and then I'm like, "Oh, man,
I'm sleepy," dah, dah, dah, dah.
And then I hear the first poem,
and then I remember
why I'm here again.
So I just wanted to make
sure that all of you were
in the same space that I was.
Also, judges, that's the longest
amount of time I'm ever going
to give you to do your scores.
Chelsea, are we ready with
the first set of scores?
>> Yes, sir.
>> Speak to 'em!
>> From low to high, we have
an 8.3, an 8.3 and a 9.2.
>> Clap it up for the poet!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
So I forgot one important thing.
I'd like to thank my very
vocal team of supporters here
in the front row
for reminding me.
If you hear a score that
you do not appreciate,
we don't boo here in this space,
we say "listen to the poem,"
because, obviously, the judges
didn't hear what we heard,
right?
So we want to make sure
that they are recalibrated
and ready for the next poem.
So let's practice.
The best poem you have ever
heard before get's a 4.4.
You say?
>> [multiple speakers]
Listen to the poem!
>> And then I say,
"Clap for the poet!"
And then you?
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Ayy! We have teams today
representing the Youth Speaks
Sacramento, the D.C.U
Slam Team and Mass LEAP.
Can we please clap for
all of those teams?
[ Cheering and Applause ]
That will be the last
time I mention the cities
until the show is over.
And, now, I think we're
ready for a poetry slam.
Chelsea, are we ready
for a poetry slam?
>> Yes, we are.
>> We are ready for
a poetry slam.
Coming up first in the stage,
please put your hands
together for Kenny!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> [multiple speakers]
We love you, poet!
We ain't never gonna
stop lovin' you, poet!
>> So in class -- in my U.S.
History class I started writing
in the margins in my textbook.
You know? Like, during class.
It'd be -- it'd be right next to
all those purposeful misprints.
You know? The glorified
mistakes.
Until, eventually, my teacher
came and told me to stop writing
on my textbook, you know,
'cuz it's not "mine to claim."
And I think she knows,
like, the stories told
through the faded
ink on the pages
that I never owned a
piece of this, you see.
This history was
not written for me.
It sings the star-spangled
banner to some,
but all I hear is a rebel yell.
And all I see are pages ready to
flip onto my skin like embers.
All I see are dead, white men
I'm supposed to mold into God,
because, half the time,
classes -- Arts and Crafts.
And we practice putting red,
white and blue construction
paper over anything
that doesn't look like it
belongs in this western scene,
and this country touched by
God, or the wrath of God.
You see, it's all
about perspective.
And perspective has always been
the footnote pressing my head
to the floor.
Concept attempting to tear
open my skull 'cuz kids strive
to be open-minded, or
as open as they want,
as open as these
textbooks can go.
And we were never supposed to
test the limits of this binding.
I constantly feel my knowledge
pressed against the walls
of this curriculum, amazed
with narrow passages,
every page a bob-wired sentence.
And I'm a heathen for believing
that there's something
on the other side.
No. For learning things that
came through between the pages
of a book, or into square math,
minds like -- like, dang --
like, how the U.S.-led genocide
on the indigenous people
of this land [inaudible],
and how it still sanctions
such slaughter, so why do we
have to glorify your forefathers
in this home of the
slave, land for the free?
It's funny how they teach
white kids about conquering,
but teach kids of color
about confinement.
>> [multiple speakers] Mmm.
>> Yup!
>> Speak to it!
>> And I'm reminded the
space for people of color
in American history has
always been in the margins.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> So one of the things
about being the host
of a poetry slam is that
you're not allowed to speak
about the poems,
because it, you know,
could sway the judges
or the audience.
So I have the ability to
think some of the people
who made this happen, and also
tell you about Split This Rock
and some of the amazing
things that happen there.
I'm gonna start by thanking
some folks real quick.
If you look to my
left over here,
you see that we have
ASL interpreters here
in this building, right?
Can we please give them a
round of applause as we attempt
to make this accessible
to all -- judges, rather.
Sorry. I gotta get
used to our new format.
Hey, Chelsea, what's up?
>> Hey.
>> Hey, you got some scores?
>> I do.
>> Read them scores out.
>> All right.
From lowest to high, we
have a 7.9 and an 8.2 --
>> [multiple speakers]
Listen to the poem!
>> And an 8.3.
>> Well, we gonna clap
for the poet, right?
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Keep that energy going for the
second poet, Keishay [phonetic]!
All the way to the stage,
keep that energy going
'til she gets to the stage.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
This the sack.
This the sack I see.
This the sack I be.
Mr. Black, Mr. Black I be.
Mr. Black, I free.
In 1865 the 13th Amendment
was written to abolish slavery
and indenture servitude.
So why do I still
feel these chains?
Thurgood Marshall did all
this work for us to go
from physical chains
to mental chains.
And now I wonder when my
people going ever be free.
Stripping these black
boys from their families.
girls from their worth.
See, um, they tell
me to go to school
so I could get a
degree for profit.
Profit, such as wealth,
money and maybe fame.
But without all that
profit, I'm just black.
And what's the profit of that?
This the sack.
This the sack I see.
Mr. Black, Mr. Black, I free.
In my school, the majority
is black and Mexican,
repetition of learning the same
history, they gentrify my school
and hood, repetition
of taking our identity.
Chained up in these uniforms,
like this professional dress
is gonna paint me white.
But I won't let them
chain my mental.
They call our school a charter,
so they're allowing them
to kick out our people.
Can't step foot in
my home school
or the boot I get,
into prison we go.
And this the sack.
This the sack I see.
Mr. Black.
Mr. Black, I free.
Blinded by kids getting
accepted to U.C.s,
forgetting that we're not
accepted in real life.
Kids dropping out of UC,
so clearly these classes
that are required, aren't
helping us in real life.
I remember when education
was actually meant to educate
and uplift the youth and help
us elevate, but now all it seems
like is a dollar
in their pocket.
>> You got this.
>> Now all it seems like is
a dollar in their pocket.
I remember when slaves were --
slaves were allowed
to read or write.
But now we're placed
in these classrooms
and forced to learn things.
And it seems like
brainwashing to me.
Schools are the new prisons.
Classrooms are the
new plantations.
Incarceration is
the new slavery.
Why are we afraid of police,
our, supposedly, protectors?
Why do kids hate a place that is
supposed to lead us to success?
Why, why, why?
Am I asking enough
questions for you?
Are you woke yet?
When I walk in these classroom
doors, stop pretending
like I'm not expected to fail,
and end up in jail or hell,
stop pretending like these
a's are going to save me.
When I walk out these school
doors, like my life isn't
at stake, like my skin color
is not a threat to society,
like I'm not playing
survival of the fittest,
praying that I make it
home safe, superintendent,
why is the school system sending
all my friends to prison?
Thank you.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> So I realized I didn't
really introduce myself.
I'm the former director of youth
programs at Split This Rock.
Yeah, things you
did in the past.
Whoo! But it's my pleasure
to be able to tell you some
of the amazing things
that they are still doing
at Split This Rock.
So they have -- in
their youth programs,
they have afterschool
clubs in ten high schools
in the D.C. metropolitan area.
They have the D.C.
Youth Slam team,
which represents D.C. every year
at the Brave New
Voices competition.
We also have two after -- excuse
me, we have two giant festivals
that happen every year.
One is called the Hyperbole.
This happens at George Mason
University where we invite
about 200 young people from
up and down the East Coast
to gather to do social justice
workshops and poetry slams.
It's amazing.
They also win a scholarship.
A thousand dollars
to go to school.
That's amazing.
You're welcome.
Also, we have Louder Than
a Bomb that we do in LTAB
in collaboration with
the Kennedy Center.
I tell you all of this
not because I expect you
to remember it, but
because I expect you
to be intrigued by it.
I expect you to say, "I
wonder what else they do."
And I expect you to go to their
website at splitthisrock.org,
and check out all of the amazing
programs that they have there.
Chelsea, are you ready to tell
them what the scores were?
>> Been ready.
>> What'd you say?
You've been ready?
Oh, okay, cool.
Go ahead then.
>> I'm gonna do it now.
From low to high, we have
a 7.8, a 7.9 and an 8.3.
[ Inaudible Speakers ]
>> Can we clap for
the poet, please?
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Coming up next to the
stage, the third poet
in the first round,
Marjahn [phonetic]!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> We see you, girl!
[inaudible] three stars!
Two more.
>> [multiple speakers] Heyy!
[ Exhales Loudly ]
>> Woman holy enough to
be marketed for marriage.
Sixteen years old.
A feisty one, loves to correct.
Can be lighter if bleached.
Last name Nadare [phonetic].
Belongs to the Royal
Family of [inaudible].
A hundred pounds,
five foot, green eyes.
Can sell her silky hair for
almost as much as sheepskin.
Cleans, up your past, smart,
despite bereft of education.
Cooks the dead flesh of the
female corpses you fail to sell,
seasons them with
propaganda faith,
serves them on a plate made
of gold that you've mined
from your mother's heart.
>> Word, come on.
>> Father taught me to never
ask for a higher dowry.
If I could speak,
I wouldn't ask why?
I would ask where you learned
to sew secrecy into our scarves,
or in submission
into our burkas.
Keep us blind until
our bodies go
from human to animal to extinct.
Where did you learn to be
the smoke from a burning fire
that our tears can't extinguish?
Women become the ash without
having ever been cold,
without having ever seen
the light in our lives,
without having ever seen warmth,
only becoming the darkness.
The wedding is the auction.
The sell-off becomes
the funeral.
The price tag, my eulogy.
Father taught me to never
wear my heart on my sleeve,
but rather in my hands
so I could crush my heart
before you get the chance to.
Shh, don't think too loud.
Remember, the opposite
of marriage is death.
The price of speaking is flesh,
unless you crave the black
and blue being bruised
onto bones.
I heard if you throw a woman
into a steel corset wedding
dress, her ribcage will crack
and you'll never
hear her scream.
Now, loo, isn't this
wedding ring pretty?
Now, look, isn't this
Admire the sleeves of henna
wrapped around my wrists,
watch these blossoms turn
to cuts because the pain
of a woman has always been
such a beautiful thing to you,
Middle Eastern in fighter,
Middle Eastern in strength.
But when did adding woman
to Middle Eastern mean less
of a survivor of war,
of rape, of womanhood?
I guess father never realized
that a woman must shine
bright before she is ash,
must bring warmth
to all cold hearts.
Woman holy enough.
Sixteen years old.
A feisty one, loves to correct.
Will set off a fire.
Watch me set off a bonfire.
Smart, despite bereft
of education.
The paradox of our eyes are that
they burn [inaudible] in a fire,
so the rest of the body melts
while you watch it happening.
Watch me stir up a
revolution, peeling the shells
of the patriarchy, mixing your
ego, insecurity, drowning them
in the oil that I cook in,
watching misogyny burn
between the bonfire.
Watch womanhood rise
above your body's ashes.
>> Wow.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> You know what
y'all should do?
If you're having a good time,
if you're being inspired,
if you're being moved,
you should go ahead
and find Split This Rock youth
programs online, @dcuslam,
on all the social medias,
because they put up clips,
they do writing prompts,
they tell you about all
of these amazing events that
are happening around town.
Every third Saturday they have
an open mic at Busboys 5th
and K. So if you have, like, a
young person looking for a space
to be, or if you're a person of
older years and you just need
to be inspired, you need
to check out @dcuslam
on all the social medias, except
for the ones that are, like,
exclusive, like Snapchat.
We don't do that yet.
But we're out there.
And there's amazing
things happening.
Chelsea, read them
scores, please.
>> From lowest to high, we
have an 8.4, a 9.1 and a 9.5.
>> Clap it up for the poet!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Coming up next, we have
Annamae [assumed spelling]!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
All the way to the stage,
let's keep that energy going.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> You got this!
>> I've been experiencing
writer's block.
But not the kind
where you can't write.
But when you can't feel.
>> Mmm, come on, poet.
>> When words fail to be seen,
and my tongue can assist me
like it once did, often I
wonder if this pen has lost all
of its courage to keep writing.
But I carry my ancestor's
bravery.
So when I get writer's
block, I find inspiration
in dancing trees,
ponding my release
from my chained mentality.
And I realize that time is
complacent, that surviving
as a black artist with anxiety
can be a suicide mission.
Some days I feel my body being
swallowed up into the belly
of white supremacy where I
am dead weight in oceans full
of bodies floating,
refusing to become ebony.
See, that's how I be.
Too afraid to swim, so I
become a wade in the water.
Too worried to be -- too
worried in being misunderstood,
so I become statuesque.
See, I was forsaken by the
same hands that birthed me,
so poetry is more than
sustaining a legacy,
but creating a family.
>> Come on.
>> You see, writing
is surviving.
It's allowing each metaphor
to drip off the tongue.
Can you taste it?
Let it be the taste of bravery.
For I don't just write
to live, I write to give.
Finding a peace of mind by
sharing this peace of mind.
Thank you.
>> Wow.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> So Split This Rock, also,
has adult programs, right?
Some would say it
started as adult programs.
It started as this
amazing festival
that happens every
two years, right?
If you want to know more
about the adult programming,
the writing workshop that
they have every first
and third Wednesday, you can
go to the back of the room,
and you can wave at those
beautiful people back there.
Wave. We have Stephanie
[phonetic]
and Malik [phonetic]
in the back.
Please go and visit them,
sign up for their listserv.
Every week they send you a
new poem, called The Poem
of the Week," a social
justice themed poem
that will make your life better.
And it's free.
All you gotta do
is go back there,
and sign up on your way out.
Please go and see all the
amazing things they're doing.
More announcements to come.
I'm ready to hear
what the scores were.
Scores from Chelsea!
>> From low to high, we have
an 8.4, an 8.4 and an 8.5.
>> Clap it up for
the poet, please!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
We got two more poets
in this first round.
Please put your hands together
for Marianna [assumed spelling]!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Go for it.
[ Exhales Loudly ]
>> A boy cut off my hair in the
seventh grade, and I still have
yet to forgive myself.
Jaylen [assumed spelling]
called me a Weavie Wonder
in a class full of
other black children,
yet I still felt stranded.
Wish my curls could spring into
action, but felt all too trapped
in a maze of braids where every
turn was just another dead end
to do anything.
In high school I've had boys run
their fingers through my kinks
and insist I ought to relax.
Rough palms and loud
voice attempt to turn me
from statue into
a body of water.
But black girls aren't supposed
to get their hair wet anyways.
I soon learned that my dark
and lovely has never
been creamed enough
to fit anyone standards.
So what do you call it when
your own people encourage you
to colonize your roots?
If hair had memory, a lineage
of African women before me
would do all they could not
to drag you back to yours.
They think damn, no foresee
could have foreseen this,
how black girl gets told
she has slay-stained curls.
So I dragged them
back to the Atlantic
where heroes is tightly packed
as ancestors on slave ships
to a time when black bodies
are being used as anchors,
and cultures and customs
were the only things
to keep us afloat.
Here is where we
learn liberation
and hair is what
brought us out history.
So you boys with your
spinning brushes and do-rags,
y'all drown us in discomfort,
but forget who put the
motion in your ocean.
[inaudible] black
hair has been the way,
but act like your momma ain't
got a head full of fudge, too.
The same boys with beady-beads
or receding hair now condemn
a sister for wearing chats,
but forget that there was a time
when our hair gave y'all life,
that runaways was dependent
on the patterns etched
on to my stop.
Them cornrows once stood up
the past of freedom aided only
by Harriet Tubman
and the North Star.
So believe me when I say
legacy dangles from every lock,
without us, would
you know their way?
Soon after masters began
cutting off the hair of the hair
of their slaves, and this
is what we considered
to be the first big chop.
It became clear that
the conditions
of our survival could be
seen through our roots
with some days, I question
if this hair has ever truly been
ours 'cuz white people have been
picking at our locks.
Like in 1979, when Bo Derek wore
cornrows for the first time.
And soon after, many other
white women copied the style.
Before this, they called it
hair-kinky, called it nappy,
called it dirty, dreadful and
unkempt, but never beautiful.
Or mine how, even now,
Kylie's out here trying
to hold a candle to my roots.
But this hair was made to
filter heat source, edges laid
and [inaudible], so don't think
I'ma bring a five, see you --
the next time y'all wanna talk
about good hair just remember
that tender head wasn't going
to pave the way to civil rights.
And what magic.
How even [inaudible] it
serves as the perfect metaphor
for this blackness, how we
black women can stretch a little
into going a long way.
I want to tell them that black
hair was once a mother's prayer,
that history, pride and
pain weaves themselves
into my cornrows every night.
I tie my scarf by
don't y'all know?
Black women have
been wearing bondage
since bondage whipping our hair
since masters been
cracking whip.
Since then my crime is
nothing but tight-fisted curls,
just learned how
to put up a fight,
has been bobbing and weaving.
[inaudible] and he, for as
long as I could remember,
now my naps stay woke,
my curls too popping
to be pressed, but jangling.
Maybe I should still feed you.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> How y'all feeling?
[ Cheering ]
Make some noise if you've heard
something that's inspired you
today so far.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
All right.
Let's put some numbers
to that inspiration.
Chelsea?
>> From low to high, we have
an 8.8., an 8.8 and a 9.5.
>> Let's clap it up
for the poet, please!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Bom, bada, bah, ba, ba, ba!
Last poet in the first round.
Put all your energy and love
together for Kofi [phonetic]!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
[ Inaudible Speakers ]
>> He ain't ready.
>> Go, poet!
[ Exhales Loudly ]
>> After Janae Johnson
[assumed spelling].
So this kid in my chemistry
class called me a nigger
so frequently you'd have thought
he had forgotten my name.
I never thought that my tongue
would betray me the way it
had others.
I sat there, looked his
bigotry square in the face.
I saw my rage clench its
fists, so I set destruction
on his surface like
mortar shells.
I made bruises on his skin
so black that it looked
like a degentrified Brooklyn.
See, maybe I shouldn't
have snapped.
See, maybe his jaw
wouldn't have, if I didn't.
See, I hit him with the water
hoses drowning out the sounds,
hit him with nightsticks
in my knuckles.
I hit him with every apology
I've ever made to this skin,
for every time nigger
made a crater in my pride,
I let it sting his like a whip.
I could've sworn I heard "no,
master" come out his lips.
But I did not stop.
I hit him for every time the
slur slipped out, serenading him
with the Sweet Chin Music.
I taught myself to
play this boy.
This boy would never
call me a nigger again.
I had won.
But this didn't happen.
I let a white boy called
me outside my name,
and I didn't fight
him, out of fear.
Or better said, out
of necessity,
because of the way my mother
reminds me of my surroundings,
I seed myself into
muzzling my angry.
She said suburbia will
suffocate her son.
Doesn't know the blunt
smoke did that already.
And ain't a blunt wrap a perfect
metaphor for my blackness?
Always being cracked open,
contents being spilled
out to make room for something
new to be consumed, to dissipate
when they are done with me.
I thought that if I let it
go, he would leave me alone.
Knew that if I struck
him off from the baton,
they will break my back.
So I sat there, and I
laughed a big, hard laugh.
>> Wow.
>> [inaudible] left
my lips as uneasily
as it ever had is my
rage, rattled its cage,
sat there in its cuffs, screamed
at the top of its lungs,
and added to the tally
another day it's been made
to lie inside of me.
I hope it knows I'm sorry.
I hope it knows -- I
hope I know I'm sorry.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> That's the end
of the first round.
How do you feel?
[ Cheering and Applause ]
I'm happy that we've
come to the understanding
that my expectation is for
you to respond with sound.
So we're good, right?
And everyone's, like,
we're good.
You know, you actually
gave it back
in the way I was looking for it.
Chelsea, are we ready
with those scores?
>> We're ready.
>> Let's go.
>> From low to high, we
have a 9.0, a 9.1 and a 9.1.
>> There we go.
There we go.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
So, as I said, that was
the end of the first round.
We're gonna run it back
in the opposite order.
But, before we do that, I
would like to introduce myself
in a way that doesn't include
something that I just did,
but more, you know,
specifically what I am doing.
Yes. My name is Joseph Green.
You can find me online
at lmsvoice.com.
I am a motivational speaker,
I'm an educational consultant,
writing curriculum,
visiting schools,
and I'm a professional
spoken word artist, also.
So you can check me out at my
website or you can follow me
at JosephLMS -- the
letters L, M, S,
like "like my status," like --
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Yes, like my status, yes.
LMSGreen. JosephLMSGreen.
I also am doing this
so that the person
who just went last has
a couple of seconds
to breathe before
we go back again.
Yeah, let him breathe, right,
'cuz y'all been doing
work up here.
I say y'all.
I'm looking at y'all as in
like the youth have
been doing work up here.
>> Right.
>> Chelsea, is there
anything you want
to share with the crowd?
I know I'm putting you on the
spot right now, but I thought,
you know, you've been in
the job now for a month,
is there a reflection you
would like to share back
to the people, or something
you would like to tell them?
>> A reflection?
>> Yes, a reflection.
>> I really appreciate all that
you did at Split This Rock.
>> Ohh, thank you, Chelsea.
I appreciate all that you're
doing at Split This Rock now.
Let's clap it up for,
Chelsea, the new director
of youth programs
at Split This Rock.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Are you ready for
the second round?
Then let's start by bringing out
the poet you just clapped for.
Coming first, Kofi!
Back, back, back again.
Clap. All that energy,
all the way to the stage!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Go, poet!
[ Exhales Loudly ]
>> [singing] You don't
know how little you matter
until you're all alone.
The product of a broken home
in the recycled store you
came with [end singing].
My mom tells me I don't
take care of myself.
And, like, she's right.
There be days when rage be the
only tongue I can call my own.
Days where I can't remember
the last embrace of my father.
Self-care is a language
I'm still learning.
Now, my life isn't
a scratching record,
meant to repeat the same tired
tune I find myself trapped in.
But I'm a man whose
masculinity is as fragile
as the ego I built it on.
That must mean that my
casket is a scratch ceiling,
my masculinity is
a bad religion,
brought me to my knees,
and asked me why I fell
in the first place.
Meaning I gave it my
devotion, and it hung me
from the same cross I thought
would bring me salvation.
My resurrection won't be
as triumphant as the one
on the third day, but
it'll be me waking
up to the second verse
of "Pink Matter."
I learned it all from Frank
Ocean, learned you take
as much time as you need to
become who you need to be.
We all grow at our own pace.
It might take four plus years
to drop a damn album,
but we'll get there.
I read his open letter, saw how
coming out cleansed his spirit.
I saw his bare bones in the
potency of his penmanship.
It almost sounded like me.
Now I couldn't truly
resonate with the story,
our experiences be different,
but I've always longed
for that same catharsis,
because I never had that.
I've always been taught I was
the man of the house, you know?
Taught to take care of
everyone and then myself.
You try not to show the broken,
so you learn to numb the pain.
"Novocain" did it best
-- the Frank Ocean song,
not actually Novocain.
Where was I?
Something about numbing pain
and how my fists numbed
every time I acquainted them
with the walls.
I got lost in the
thrill of it all.
I let it linger.
It's the only way
I've ever remembered
that I am my father's son.
It's the only sliver of manhood
I haven't learned from him.
See. the men in my family
don't really get it like that.
But Frank does.
See, the men in my
family are children
of the sun with obsidian hearts.
Meaning they're black
and beautiful
and cold and hard to crack.
I ain't never seen
my father cry.
I only seen my brother cry once.
I ain't cried since
the death of me.
My grandfather, past tense,
Frank Ocean has that
project, right?
"Boys Don't Cry."
But I'm learning that tears tear
away the turmoil of any trauma.
And, because of that, I'm
making peace with my soul.
Because of that, I'm
praying for peace
of mind, of rain from the sky.
Like, man, I guess
what I'm trying
to say is Frank Ocean taught
me how to love myself,
taught me to take my time,
taught me that not being okay
is okay, because I never looked
at myself as anything
more than a burden.
I always thought myself to
be a Kinder Atlas holding
up the weight of the world
on strained shoulders
and straight knees.
I've reprised my
desire to do it solo.
But I'm learning to take
care of myself in a way
that won't worry my mom,
or while turning my
casket's scratched ceiling
into an open door, I'm learning
that this is a sweet life.
That I'd rather chip my pride
than lose my mind out here.
It wasn't Frank Ocean
that I thought would help
me experience this epiphany,
because, in all honesty,
[singing] I'm used
to being closed off, yeah.
Ain't used to being wrong.
Now you are and I
am madly involved,
madly involved [end singing.]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Sometimes you
just have to let it.
Chelsea, are we ready
with the scores?
>> Yes, sir.
>> Awesome.
>> From low to --
>> Yeah, no, that's
some good time.
I don't know why.
Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, we're gonna
work it out.
We got five --
>> Okay.
>> More to go.
>> All right.
I'm gonna go.
>> Yes.
>> Low to high, got a
9.2, a 9.3 and a 9.4.
>> Clap it up for
the poet, please!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Coming up next, Marianna!
>> Ay, oh, Farcy [phonetic]?
>> Yay?
>> Talk to them how
the bathroom set up.
>> Dirty. Eww.
>> Go, poet.
We pray that no harm on thy
children may fall, that blessing
and peace may descend on us all,
so that we may serve thee
ever alone land that we love,
our Sierra Leone -- for whom.
Africa produces three-quarters
of the world's diamonds,
but not all come cut, cleaned
and polished into perfection.
Some grow black spots
we call graphite.
They say the clarity
of these stones depends
on the size of their impurities.
But the most prized diamonds
are not usually found
in poorer colors.
The irony in this is that
they're cultivated in its reign
as jagged as mountaintops,
dug up by people with eyes
like ivory and skin
the color of obsidian,
in a continent whose
pain is often overlooked.
It's safe to say that
like these stones,
my mother's land has been
flawed since the beginning.
When I think of home,
my sweat-slicked chest
become speckled with blood
as hand turns to stump
and white owner see's sun.
For the first time, I am a
girl dripping with the history
of a war-torn country,
but my people don't bleed.
Our diamonds do it for us.
When the conflict
ensued, my parents fled.
So I can't tell you what it was
like to have grown up there.
So I've seen the severed hands
or witnessed the
limp lifeless bodies,
but even as an Acasa I can tell
you of fear, I can tell you
that the fear of being
forgotten in a land made foreign
to you scares us more than
your Ebola virus is doing.
All I have left to ask
is to the employees
of De Beers Mining Company,
what do you have to say
for yourselves when the
wellbeing of a group
of people can matter less
to you than the amount
of rough you are able to pocket?
And Sierra Leone translates
to the Lion Mountains
in Italian then Pedro
de Centre [phonetic].
Just how quickly are we
to become the pride
of a dying breed?
Words reduced to remnants and
human beings turned beasts
of no nation to Americans.
Do you know what
it's like to live
in a country that
loves you back?
I'm both black and Muslim,
and learning more as the more
in America that not all men
were created equal if the death
of one can outweigh
that of another.
If Sheila Abdus-Salaam can
show up dead in a river,
and have her passing
be called a suicide.
I stand as the fifth
of six children
of two third-world
immigrant parents
who have never let me forget
that words are sharper
than swords.
So as Sierra Leone
stands as number 180
on the World Health Organization
list of disparaged countries,
as I call my grandmother
from the privileged end
of a Boss telephone card to
speak for only ten minutes,
and a savagery continues
to run through the pinnacle
of these veins in a [inaudible]
community, I am reminded
that this is not for the
32-carat wedding band sitting
happily ever after
on your finger.
This is for the people suffering
every day just so it can happen.
This is for the jollof
rice would taste
so tantalizing it
surpasses every other.
But, most of all, this
is an elegy written
for the people whose
names I don't know,
but whose country I come
from, because this is
for Sierra Leone, and you trying
to turn diamonds into dust,
but forgetting we are resilient.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> We got any writers
in the audience?
Just show your hands.
This is a show-your-hands-type
question.
All right, cool.
Anybody in the audience
that ever thought
that they might want to
do, like, an open mic,
or perform in front
of a group of people,
but they haven't done it yet?
Just a show of hands.
All right, cool, cool, cool.
There are some spaces that you
can go to to pursue that dream.
I told you as a young person
you can go every third Saturday,
5th and K, Busboys and
Poets is the youth open mic.
But if you're an adult and
you want to do the same thing,
we have a little event
that happens every third Sunday
sponsored by Split This Rock
and Busboys and Poets
called Sunday Kind of Love.
That happens at Busboys
and Poets,
14th and V. There's a community
of people out there ready
and wanting and willing
and needing to embrace you
and your art and your
craft and your story.
So please take these
opportunities and join us,
because once you
get up on this side
of the microphone,
it only gets better.
Chelsea, you ready?
>> Ready.
>> Let's go.
>> From low to high, we
have a 9.0, a 9.1 and a 9.2.
>> Clap it up for
the poet, please!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Coming back to the
stage, the third poet
in the second round, Annamae!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Go, poet!
>> Have you got something
to say --
>> Say something!
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> I think he forgot
I was black.
Like I was too far
from the unknown,
scientists called
me an abnormality.
Lacking too much vitamin D,
that's why my skin
looked this way.
But he, with his light
brown eyes and silver smile,
told me I was too
cute for a black girl.
Like he forgot my
skin wasn't passed
down by solid kings
and beautiful queens.
Like he forgot my skin wasn't a
symbol for the metal in my back,
the sass in my hips,
the ocean in throat.
This boy forgot I was forgotten
letters sent by my father,
stamped with the year 2000.
He forgot I was a silver spoon
scooped with chocolate kisses.
He missed my black privilege
to say I lived past
my days of puberty.
So I shall not apologize for
wearing this black hoodie
on my black skin, and shout
to Trayvon Martin for dying
for my sins, the skin lost
in the horizons of the sun,
my skin lifted hand, swayed hips
and afro baby blues, our skin.
Baby, this kind of blackness
runs through our veins,
roots so deep call us the
tree of life, call me black,
call me oppression, call
me obituary, call me quick,
call me insane, call me the
black girl without a brain.
But if you want me to be
anything out of this range,
then you can keep the change.
Thank you.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> I keep having these moments
where I think to myself,
"How cool is this," --
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Right, that the Library of
Congress not only, you know,
they do the National
Book Festival.
Oh, that's amazing.
But, like, every year for the
past four years they've insisted
and worked really hard with us.
It's not easy putting this
together, getting young people
from all over the
country together.
Every year for the last four
years, they've invested time
and money into this
event right here.
I just want to shout out
to the Library of Congress,
because we'd be in front
of the -- the -- the --
the Convention Center
doing a poetry circle
without them right now.
So [inaudible] thank you.
I'm catching up.
Chelsea?
>> From low to high, we
have an 8.6, an 8.7, an 8.8.
>> Clap it up for
the poet, please!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> So much paper,
so little time.
Now, the fourth poet
in the second round,
please put your hands
together for Marjahn.
All the energy, all
the way to the stage.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> You got this.
>> You got this, poet.
>> A letter to the
baby I aborted.
What was I supposed to do
when you asked who Baba is?
What would I do then?
Would I tell you the only
time I saw him he reeked
of cigarette butts
lit out by moonshine,
threw $11 to my feet before
abandoning this corpse
on the edge of 17th Street.
I miss you, today more than
I missed you yesterday.
What am I supposed to
fill the empty space with?
How am I supposed to empty
your fragments twisted
into lumps throughout my soul,
the words "I am" are
slowly becoming "I was,"
slowly becoming "we were."
I've shattered my glass
heart back into loneliness,
cut my fingers trying to
jigsaw-puzzle us back together.
And what was I supposed to do?
What if you had his eyes?
What if every time
I looked at you,
I'd watch your eyes unearth
all the wrong parts of me,
unearth all the shoved screams
from the basement of my belly,
the puncturing pain
piercing my body,
remembering how he left every
frozen muscle in me burning.
What if you were the
spitting image of your father?
What if every time we
locked eyes, I saw him?
What if you had his smile?
Every time we'd laugh I'd
hear his contempt echoing
in the empty aches of my womb.
And they say blood is
thicker than water,
but blood is never thicker
than my fetus slaughtered.
Why can't water flood
the graveyard of my body,
wash away the sins
on your tombstone?
And here I am, planning
the funeral
for a child that
was never alive.
Is this missing you, or
the emptiness you fill?
Is this love, or guilt?
Only heard you singing in
the soft hums of cold wind,
never heard your prayers.
Only felt your hands
slipping from the monkey bar
of my ribcage, never fisting
around mommy's finger.
And every time I
watch the sunset,
I know what would have
been your favorite color.
And every time I see myself,
I know what you were
supposed to look like.
You were supposed
to have my smile.
You were supposed to be the
spitting image of your mother,
because you were going to
teach me to love myself,
because I would have loved you.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Chelsea, are you
ready with the scores?
>> From low to high, we
have a 9.0, a 9.6 and a 9.7.
>> Can we clap it up
for the poet, please!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Coming up next to the stage,
please put your hands
together for Keishay!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Have you got something
to say?
>> [multiple speakers]
Say something!
>> Go, poet.
>> [speaking in a
child's voice] Hi,
my name Michele [assumed
spelling] and I four year old.
Mommy and Daddy not
together no more,
but there's still
my third Christmas.
This year I spent
at Daddy house.
Momma bought me Apple Bottom
jeans, and daddy bought me boots
with the fur, so you
know how I rockin' it.
My stepbrother say he got
a special present for me.
And I just can't wait to see it.
I really hate surprises,
so I keep bugging.
He told me don't worry
because it's real big.
My stepbrother's
really the best.
He took me to the back room,
he gave me the biggest piece
of candy -- or I thought
it was a piece of candy.
I was scared, but who backs
down to sweets [end
speaking in a child's voice]?
It's always just
been me and my mom.
I couldn't believe it when
she said I couldn't go
to my dad's anymore.
Every time I came
back from his house
in the summer I gained
a little weight.
I didn't know if it was
because of the depression,
or all the candy.
My father said she was just
trying to keep me away from him.
But I guess he never noticed
my stepbrother's sweet tooth.
I hated my mom.
When in reality,
she was just trying
to protect me from other sweets.
But by the time the
cavities came in,
there wasn't really
much she could do,
because Medi-Cal
wouldn't cover it.
The therapist wouldn't
take our insurance.
Nobody to help.
My tooth began to decay, and
it felt like I was rotting
from inside to out,
turning white
to yellow to brown to black.
And I'm still rotting.
I always knew diabetes
were genetic,
but I never knew you could catch
a disease from a sweet tooth.
I'm the cutest 16-year-old
you'll ever see.
These dudes stay hitting
me, but I don't want them,
because all they
wanna do is hit.
I met this one dude, and I
think I kind of like him.
But every time he hugs me
and his hands touch my waist,
I begin to feel wasted.
Like, uh, uh, like I
forgot how to talk.
Anyways, I'm hecka grown, and I
don't need a dude for nothing.
I got all these girls hecka mad
because their dude wants me.
But my father just got out of
jail, and he swear he father
of the year, but where was
here when I got cavities?
Where was he to help pay
to repair my sweet tooth?
He tried to come in
my life and raise me
like I wasn't already grown.
I got enough dudes.
I don't need him.
I be straight hustlin'.
I got a dude who get my nails
done, one to pay my phone bill,
one to take me out, and,
of course, one for pipe.
Oh, and I work at
the CVS Center.
These customers hella annoying.
Hello. Welcome to
the CVS Center.
How may I help you?
I never thought I'd
feel like this again.
It's so hot in here.
I'm starting to get anxiety.
I -- I -- I can't breathe.
Can they turn the air on?
It's like -- it's like the devil
himself is standing in front
of me pulling me down to hell.
I went on my break.
I called my momma.
I told her I saw my stepbrother,
and he smiled at me.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> So every year Split This
Rock has a poetry contest.
It's an opportunity where
they open up the contest
to all members of the community.
It is called the Sonia
Sanchez-Langston Hughes
Poetry Contest.
Let's put a little
weight behind it, right?
We're not playing around.
There's some good examples
that we're looking to.
This year the poetry contest
is open until November the 1st,
and is judged by Franny Choi.
So if you don't know
who Franny Choi is,
and you just heard these young
people get really excited
about it, do two things: one,
look up Franny Choi; and, two,
go to splitthisrock.org
and contribute your poetry
to this poetry contest.
First place winner, 500 bucks
and you get to spit your poem
at the Poetry Festival.
That's a big deal.
Clap it up for poetry contest!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
As a means for us to share
powerful pieces of art
and making the world
a better place.
>> [multiple speakers] Yeah!
>> Yeah. Not just a contest.
Chelsea, scores please?
>> From low to high, we have
an 8.9, a 9.0 and a 9.1.
>> Clap it up for the poet!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
And this is it!
We've made it to the
last poet of the round.
Put your hands together
for Kenny!
All the way back.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> [inaudible] you do.
>> Three stars!
>> [multiple speakers]
Two stars.
Heyy.
>> Go, poet.
>> Prom night 2017!
Prom night 2017!
I'm taking the lint from
the inside of my pockets.
And I'm taking the
middle-school snowstorm.
And I'm taking the squeak of
my kicks through the hall.
Yo, I'm taking the Dean's List.
Though I was never on it.
And -- and I'm taking
the awards cabinet.
Though I was never in it.
And I'm taking a
bottle of Sprite,
and I'm gonna be caressing
its curves, like I'm halfway
through an all-nighter
with less than half
of the necessary word count.
I'm taking Blaziken,
Abomasnow and Piplup.
>> What?
>> Yes, I said Piplup.
PokeChat me with small talk
is an HM, and I'll be there
with every show I
ever binge-watched
when I was supposed
to be breaking
down quadratic equations.
I'm taking every
hole in my bookbag.
I'm taking every hole and every
pair of sneakers I've ever had.
I have so many holes.
You'd have thought me
by now an empty man.
I fill my body up with
my voice some days just
to remind myself what I
have left to hold on to.
And prom night 2017,
I arrived alone.
Fear lacing the inside
of my collar,
standing like a last-second
decision waiting
to shrink back into oblivion.
But then I see my friends.
And you'd have thought them
lighthouses the way they waved,
see?
High school was a hurricane.
And we were always
caught standing outside.
They still make me smile,
like this is just
another Saturday night.
And after the music ends,
after we step back outside
into the cool mouth of
night and make peace
with our toes stuffed
inside these dress shoes
and our laughter, like a
dandelion finding the slivers
of light, finding its way into
every corner of every eye in us,
a flock of smiles
breaking fly for winter,
band of black beardless bandits
come to steal the star shine,
back room bootleg binge
watchmen open our jackets
like we're trying to let the
whole world inside our part.
After the music ends, after
the dance floor clears
like a holiday tabletop,
you find your forehead wet
with whatever your
footwork managed to kick up.
The magic dissolved means the
house lights, the doors open
and let all that stank out.
We step up, come from out of the
cut again, and this is our part,
plays like PlayStation
and school bell,
and anime and awkward.
[ Cheering ]
And awkward silences.
And however we learn to cope
with the world to familiar
with a bend of our
backs, and too eager
to see the way we drop
belonging, is to only ever come
when the night is
over, when we're left
in the corner of
everyone's eyes.
Our dance outcast into
spotlight, hitting VOC
and ninjutsu all
in one pose chop.
But we feel in our bones
like this is GTA 5 Million,
like it's about that time
at Asgard to Ragnarok.
And only O knows the
way our steps fill up,
like when Bruce Banner's fed up.
This is radioactive.
So by the time we fall out
to an IHOP, we are glowing,
brought together by a night we
had all calendared with dread,
our song barbeque-stained
with cynicism and regret.
But the tune, still sweet,
I hum it again and again,
hold close to the
notes, trying my best
to never forget,
to never forget.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Chelsea, can you read
those scores out, please?
>> From low to high, I have
a 9.2, a 9.3 and a 9.3.
>> Clap it up for the poet!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
So allow me to recap a couple
of things you should know.
My name is Joseph Green.
If you want to know
more about me,
you can follow me
online at JosephLMSGreen.
I'm the CEO of an
educational consulting company
and motivational speaker
and spoken word poet.
I am the former director
of youth programs
at an amazing organization
that co-sponsored this event.
They're called Split This Rock.
Yes. Split This Rock.
Right? You can find them
online at aplitthisrock.org.
They do amazing programming
for both adults
and youth throughout
the nation, right?
They have an amazing
presence here in the city,
but they also have
poetry and events
that span the world, actually.
Also, a big thanks to
the Library of Congress
for making space for this event.
Yeah, [inaudible] wrap that up.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Right now if I could have
all the young people,
including the sacrificial
poet that touched the stage.
Come back up to the stage real
quick, I would appreciate it.
Come up to the stage.
Y'all can clap for them as
they come up to the stage.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> That's appropriate.
That's very appropriate.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Poetry saves lives.
Literally, figuratively.
Figuratively, we've
all had that one day
where that one thing pushed
us too far to the edge,
and that one song,
that one line,
that one movie brought us back.
Literally, there are
classrooms, spaces filled
with young people throughout
this entire country working
relentlessly on work on
-- excuse me, on words,
on craft, on creating poems.
That act, that actual act,
those after-school
programs are saving lives.
If you believe that --
because it makes perfect sense,
doesn't it?
If you believe that, if you
witnessed that here today,
please support programs
like Split This Rock.
All right?
If you want to know
more about them,
they're right back
there at that table.
Now, I would like to call
to the stage the director
of youth programs at Split
This Rock, Chelsea Iorlano.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
And Robert Casper!
They will be announcing
the winners.
>> Thank you, Joseph.
So we are going to announce
the top three poets: third,
second and first place.
And the prize is that Rob
has come up here to hand
out some books that are signed
by the current poet laureate,
and Elizabeth Acevedo's book
is part of that prize as well.
So can I get a drumroll, please,
as I announce the poet that came
in third place is Marianna.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
And in second place,
drumroll, please, for Kofi!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
And, in first place, the winner
of this year's National Book
Festival Youth Poetry Slam
is Marjahn!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> If y'all had a good
time, I need y'all
to make a whole lot
of noise right now.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
On behalf of the
Library of Congress,
on behalf of Split This Rock,
on behalf of myself thank
you all for coming out.
Have a good night!
And come and talk to a
poet on your way out,
meet somebody, shake a hand!
[ Cheering and Applause ]